good evening
members um
gentlemen in the public gallery and
offices welcome to this planning
committee meeting of the 18th of august
2021
as always a little bit of housekeeping
if i may um if the firearm is activated
please vacate the offices via the stairs
either through the security door
to my right it's the one
on your
left or whatever way you look at it
uh please do not use the lifts
yeah thank you
thank you mr allman thank you i'll
counsel all them uh please do not use
the lift because i don't see if the
money isn't working assembly in hawley
square
until officers
um come over or whatever and speak to
you
and we can return to this chamber
does anybody intend filming
no okay thank you
restriction of mobile phones with
everybody present please ensure their
mobile phones are turned to silent
and they
are not used to make or receive phone
calls in the chamber whilst this meet
his meeting is in
progress
members requesting to speak under 20
council procedure 20.1
i can't see any other members who aren't
on committee um james i don't think
thank you very much
[Music]
public speaking uh the following
applications have been reserved for
public speaking but please members note
that agenda item four b
uh a zen draw
farm i hope i've spent it
said it right there farmhouse hayne road
ramsgate
moving on to our agenda agenda item one
apologies for absence
are there any apologies for absence
thank you we don't have any there
agenda item two uh declarations of
interest
remembers
no agenda item 3 uh the minutes of the
planning committee on the 21st of july
2021
do members agree that the minutes of the
planning committee meeting held on the
21st of july be approved and signed by
the chair could i have a proposal please
counselor coleman cook a second please
councillor robin the members agree
thank you members
agenda item four is the schedule of
planning applications and public
speaking
uh any site visits um which i think we
could be looking forward to at some
stage
will be taking place on friday the third
of september
agenda item 4b plan application
r02
central
farm house i'm sure i'll be picked up on
that but the hain road ramsgate
speaking in favor of the application is
mr hare mr hair you have three minutes
please
thank you
thank you chair
uh thank you chair and good evening
members and officers the officer's
report accepts that the farmhouse is
vacant extensively fire damaged and the
site is largely overgrown
my client would therefore like to think
members will agree that this proposal
will represent a significant improvement
to the visual amenities and appearance
of the area through the tiding up of the
current eyesore and its replacement with
a well-designed contemporary residential
scheme
reflecting the character of a farmyard
courtyard which is deemed acceptable by
officers
indeed the report confirms the site now
lies within the urban area being of low
density the scale of development would
not appear in congrega it would sit
comfortably within the context of the
building's opposite it would not appear
out of keeping with a form and pattern
of development in the area and that
existing and proposed planting will
largely shelter the development from
longer views which can be maintained in
accordance with a long-term management
plan
whilst the report mentions previous
removal of trees this was carried out
following inspection by a tree surgeon
whereby hazardous trees with visible
signs of rot at the base and leaning
over the highway had to be removed also
many were self-seeded sycamores growing
at angles with split trunks making them
unstable and with intertwined root
systems affecting the stability of
others
all other trees have been retained
especially to the perimeters away from
the road along the strong mature single
uh along with the strong mature single
trunk trees to the center of the plot
which have been incorporated into the
proposed layout
further visual benefits will occur from
the fact that the site features
prominently on the approach into than it
from two major arterial roads and that
the setting of the listed building's
opposite will be enhanced with the
officers report confirming that the
development would not result in harm to
the setting or historic features of the
listed buildings at osengul grange the
report also indicates that ecology
enhancement and archaeological matters
can be dealt with by condition there
will be no adverse impact on residential
amenities of existing occupiers and the
development is acceptable in terms of
space standards and provision of
immunity space
as acknowledged by officers the title
balance is in favor of granting consent
now applies but which was not considered
to be the case by the inspector at the
time of the previous appeal
members therefore now have the
opportunity to consider refresh whether
the harm alleged in terms of a
perception of harm to pedestrian safety
which will not arise as
as residents will not attempt to walk
along hayne road but will have the
opportunity to use the adjoining bridal
way or the alleged unsustainable
location despite its proximity to
ramsgate and manson both of which are
within easy cycling distance
significantly and
this significantly and demonstrably
outweighs the benefits of clearing the
present eyesore and creating an
attractive courtyard development which
will contribute to the supply of housing
finally the application had no
objections and i think it no public
objection sorry and i think it is clear
local residents want something to happen
here especially given the support seen
in common the comments section of the
recent art of fanuc news facebook post
thank you
thank you very much mr hair um and i'll
start planning off so [ __ ] annabelle
evans too
yes could you please turn your mic off
if you would push the button
thank you uh
uh our planner officer will give the
report
thank you chair and this is the
application site outlined in red
um this is the application site an
aerial view of it within its context so
it's this square here in the middle of
the
slide
um
opposite side is ozengel grange which is
a listed um
manor house with analystic barn
to give it some context we have manston
road running across the slide in this
sort of area
we have the manston tescos here
and we have hane road which separates
the application site from moss and gel
grange
so zooming in on that aerial this is the
application site and as has been talked
about there were this is quite an old
picture of the site there were a number
of trees along the site including along
the boundary of hain road and along all
the boundaries of the site some of those
trees have now been cleared
so just look at some photographs of the
site this is the fire damaged wedding
that sits on the site that has been
mentioned
again this is another view of the site
this is one of the trees that has
remained on the site you can see some
trees to the rear of the site here and
you can see some evidence of fly tipping
that is on the site
again this is another view of the site
and we're looking
um towards the western boundary here
these trees sit along the western
boundary and you can see a car
along hayne road so you can see some of
those trees that did run along the
frontiers of the site
at hayne road have had been removed
and the site here is on the left hand
side of the photograph
so you can see some trees still remain
around the boundaries
and this is looking with the site on the
right hand side so you can see
some trees remaining the fire damaged
building and some trees to the rear of
the site and along the edges here so
that gives it the context of some trees
still being
retained to the boundaries of the site
at the moment
so this existing site plan
as we've just seen so you have the
access road here
the fire damage building here
this is the proposed um
site plan
and as has been mentioned it will be a
sort of courtyard farmyard style
development with the six houses
running around
a central sort of area here with some
landscaping
and maintaining and using the existing
access
this is a proposed ground floor so of
all units
and you will see that they are served by
private amenity spaces they have parking
there is some visitor parking within the
site
this is the first floor
plan
it might be slightly difficult to see
but essentially there are two
three bed dwellings and four four bed
units within the site
just have a quick look at some of the
sections
within the site to give you some idea of
the design of the buildings
so section a a at the top is looking
through the middle of the site
and looking towards the rear so that's
where the four houses that you saw
would be sitting
section b below is what you'd see it's a
section closest to hane road
and you can see the site access here
in this area
site section c is looking across the
site going from hane road to the
countryside
on the
left hand side to the west hand side of
the site
and section dd below
is looking at the eastern side so the
right hand side if you was looking at
site from hayne road
essentially you can see here that the
post weddings are quite traditional in
design they do not seek to mirror or
replicate any particular form of
development but they use traditional
materials have pitched roofs and are two
stories in height and they are
considered to be acceptable in terms of
design
this is a
landscaping plan and as has been
mentioned
there are a number of trees
that will be
added to the site and these are the ones
shown in yellow the yellow circles here
there will also be
the brown circles you see here are the
existing trees that have been retained
um and there will be
a variation of different
planting and things that private amenity
areas areas will be garden areas and
planted obviously the desire of
the applicants the
future occupiers of those units there is
an open area of landscaping proposed
here which is shown to be a wildflower
meadow
and there is a a part of garden wall
here but the rest of the boundary
treatment is
said to be poster rail fencing to give
it a more
rural feel and character
so
yeah as has been
mentioned the proposals we use the
existing access to oppose dwellings no
objections racist by kcc highways and
this plan does shows the visibility
displays um that can be achieved and
they are considered adequate and
acceptable and there's been no objection
raised by kcc about the number of
traffic movements that will be generated
by the development
excuse me
members would have seen in the report
there is a link or
a link being made with this site and the
surrounding mansion green development
that's
been approved at least in part around
the site so i'll hand over to mr
and to give a brief update in relation
to that
hi members um so
this is the illustrative layout that was
approved uh as uh for the outline
application for manson green members
will remember we discussed madison green
in terms of um sort of proposed changes
to the planning contributions that were
being made with regards to a
um
a housing infrastructure fund bid a year
and a half ago or so
um
the the context of the application site
um really does link to the mansion green
development so it was approved outline
consent in uh july 2016
for 785 houses
you'll see the application site is
basically right in the center of this
and and this application was approved
before the local plan was adopted the
local plan being adopted
included the allocation of this site
which moved the urban confines to the
west
which basically then led to inclusion of
madison green within the urban confines
so the proposed development for mansion
green
is linked to three main phases the first
phase of development is the one in light
green which we're going to look at in a
little bit of detail in a second um that
has proposed about 220 houses
the blue phase is phase 2
which is about 280 odd houses and then
phase 3
to the
west of the existing haine road
in beijing orange
is the rest of the houses up to the 785
um
the link road that you will have seen on
the left hand side
um is proposed to go
would be required to be provided before
phase three
um any units on phase three are occupied
and that in turn would lead to the
downgrading of hane road so all the
traffic would run around the outside of
the site
so that's what was sort of secured
through the outline we've also got the
original parameter plan for the
development to give an idea of where all
the various linkages for both vehicles
and pedestrians would come from
this plan
indicates that phase three
on the uh on the west of the site and
and on the left-hand side of the image
that you can see
would have a sort of pedestrian route um
along the hain road um linking to that
linking to the houses that would be
coming forward in phase three but you
will also see running along the the very
south directly adjacent to this site a
link from the the new hane road a
pedestrian link all the way through
along an existing bridleway route that
would then wrap around the edge of the
ozinjo grange site and then connect back
in and this part is is phase one for uh
development in monster green
so
the phase one application was submitted
um
just about almost three years ago
it was approved in october 2019. so with
the original outline application
it was granted permission for all the
reserve matters applications to be
submitted within five years of that
original outline
so what that gave was up until july this
year for all three phases to be
submitted to the council first phase
came in as i said a few years ago it was
approved in october 2019 and they've got
two years to implement that reserve
matters for that phase so that means
that that phase has to be implemented by
october this year
to be extant to be able to be built out
and the applicant has submitted a number
of details to discharge the
pre-commencement conditions they've
either been already discharged although
with the council now with the clear
intention they are going to implement
that development at phase one so that
permission will then be extend
we have received both applications for
phases two and three
they came in before the july deadline
this year
and they will be and one of them is
already valid um and it was it was on
the weekliest this week i believe um for
phase two uh with phase three still
invalid but it's within the time frame
so that we will be considering that
development
so
in terms of this phase that you can see
you can see it includes
um sorry to get my mouse pointer up
there so you'll see it includes a
an emergency vehicle access onto the
hane road which is not for normal use of
vehicles
the design and access statement on the
reserve matters makes it clear that will
only be provided with the pedestrian
link when the road has been downgraded
because of the moment hayne road
is um he's still the primary route in um
you know from lord of the manor to
westwood cross
um but you can see where the arrow is
that shows the the um the emergency
access route with a path that be
provided so as i mentioned this this
phase has 220 dwellings in the council's
annual monitoring report which looks at
uh projections of when
housing sites that have either already
got consent are going to come forward
using communication provided by the
agents it indicates that
the first phase of development in the
financial year 2022 to 2023 so starting
next april
it's it's expected that 20 units on this
phase would be provided in that year
period
and
as of today
we do not have confirmation that there
is a confirmed house builder for this
phase of development
it is expected as i say that the land
agent that's clearing all the conditions
will implement this consent they will
get on site they will dig the trenches
in accordance with the commission
to make the consent be extend and then
be able to be implemented but as far as
we are aware there is no confirmed house
builder yet for for phase one
thank you
so we need to get back fine
yeah thank you
um just an update uh to continue
talking about the highway issues that
have been mentioned
hayne road is obviously a busy road i'm
sure most members know it it's a 60 mile
speed limit and mostly unlit and there
are no footpaths on either side of the
road along the frontage of this
particular
application site or for several meters
either way of it
the application would propose a footpath
along the very front edge of the site
so along just at the actual front of the
application site but it can go no
further because the rest of the land is
not within its ownership
so concerns are raised by officers and
kcc highways about the safety of
future occupiers of the site who would
be likely to walk in the carriageway of
hayne road to get to bus stops or
services and amenities
and as i said kcc have objected to the
application which is quite rare but they
are saying and state the site would not
be provide safe access for pedestrian
cyclists and recommend refusal on that
basis
the applicants as has as we have already
um said and set out in the report link
the application with the matson and
green development
and that this would provide the missing
pedestrian links and make the
development safe for pedestrians and
cyclists in the future together with the
downgrading of haine road itself
as has been set out in the report and
has been mentioned this application
essentially the same application
has come before us before for the six
dwellings and did go to appear on was
dismissed at appeal in assessing the
appeal the inspector considered the
sustainability of the site in relation
to its location and highway safety was
the principal issue and he concluded
that manson
sorry phase one of the manston green
development when complete would provide
safe pedestrian cycle access for the
occupants of the site albeit they would
have to cross hayne road to get to the
link to the south of the site
but he did raise concerns that there was
no indication of when work would begin
on that phase
although but
let alone when it would be completed and
that there was no time scale for the
other phases of the manston green
development
coming forward
and therefore the
and therefore also the associated
downgrading of haine road he went on to
dismiss the appeal on the basis that the
development would not be sustainable in
environmental terms
due to occupiers having to rely on
private vehicles
and also issues of highway safety
since that time and as has been
explained by ian
the reserve matters phase one of manston
green has been submitted and approved
and works must commence before of
october 2021
but the completion date for this phase
is not within the control of the council
or the applicant
the applicant for this current
application we're looking at tonight
at this present time there is no
certainty that footpaths for mansion
green development will come forward or
indeed that all phases of the
development will come forward
even if this were to be the case it is
considered by officers that this small
development is likely to come forward
prior to the manston green improvements
being in place and the downgrading of
haine road given the smaller scale of
its development of only six houses
so officers are therefore recommending
refusal on the basis of highway safety
for pedestrian cyclists and again the
site being uns sustainable
due to the reliance having for future
occupiers having to rely on private
vehicles
to access amenities and facilities
thank you chair
uh thank you annabelle
um i move that the officer's
recommendation is adopted could the vice
chair please second
or second merchant thank you council
carmen cook members
council robin
yeah thank you chair um
interesting
um
personally you know i've been in the old
house
many many years ago when mr palo used to
own it
and uh
back back then
[Laughter]
i'll try that one
back in those days share that
[Music]
um
of course back in those days chair there
wasn't the amount of traffic
that that there is now
um that does worry me
the issue of the uh
traffic along there and anybody walking
along there i certainly wouldn't walk
along there um i don't know that anybody
else here would
um
you can't
tell that they will never want to walk
along there
things happen and things will need to be
you know people would need to to walk at
some time or other um
the fact that the
site is a to want of a better phrase and
i saw
because people are fly shipping on it
that's not a reason for us to grant
planning consent
uh we we've got to look at it as as it's
been said that the sustainability of it
uh we can't has been said as well we
don't we don't know when the manchester
green development will take place um
and
i i i agree with the officer's report
chair thank you
uh thank you councillor alban i didn't
really want to say that you were
wrestling with two microphones
thank you uh council heart
thank you chair um i mean agreeing i
hate to say it with mr auburn i mean i
think um that it's
where it is i we all know the hain road
it's a it's a
okay a lot of cars don't go more than 30
because it's blocked up but i mean of an
evening it does fly around um but i
think if they're going to build this it
should be when phase 3 is done and the
road is declassified and also i think
they need to have what did you say as
you look at the picture where that
road's going through that's a is that a
bridal whale is that footpath that red
on the left as you look at
the buildings
so that line that's coming through is
that footpath
by the way but realistically you know if
it gets to if it ever gets planning i
mean i think that they should have
access to that so they can walk into the
estates and go that way because you know
there's nowhere for them to go even as a
downgraded road i mean
they just can't walk anywhere so i think
they've got to have a way of getting out
onto a pedestrian area
thank you council councillor joel
bayford
thank you chair i agree with everything
that's been said
um i know there are remote places where
um
cars are necessary and everything else
but as councilwoman said
traffic has changed beyond recognition
this is a busy road and
i just don't think that personal safety
can um be
uh
what's the word
thank you um
it's a pity because i think this is an
attractive development and i think it it
will be good
if manson green goes ahead but i think
it has to be one for the future and not
not until then
thank you
thank you for cancer
thank you chad i agree my uh other
counsellors on this
um looking at it i don't think i could
live with myself passing this in this
present condition
um if there was to be an accident on
that road then
um i could never live with myself
afterwards once the phase one is
complete and the road is downgraded and
they've got the footpath going across
and possibly even a crossing there then
that would be the time that we would go
for that kind of
uh development the development itself
looking at it looked great but uh
not with that road at uh in the
condition it is now pretty good chair
uh thank you councillor keane
thank you chair um i just wanted some
clarification for the um the grange is
that a residential building or what is
that and how
and so how do they
you know they don't have a footpath
either
[Music]
yeah they yes indeed those those two
properties including i suppose the
property that's now derelict
um yeah in india they didn't have
pedestrian access but as i think council
auburn said obviously when they were
built that road wasn't in any way that
the primacy that it has now in terms of
vehicular movements so whenever it
occurred you know they would all
they were all pre the planning system
in fact
uh council patmore
thank you chair
could i just ask uh
how long will it be before they'd build
the new hane road
because you were going to get a bus if i
remember rightly a bus was going to come
down the old
hayn road through the center
of the development
and uh it was for buses only no cars
from there to their sort of thing
and so as mentioned we've we've got
specific time scales in terms of when
each phase needs to start one thing i
didn't i suppose explain which is
relevant for members um is
for phases two and three and three being
the particularly important one because
it will provide the new road and then
through
that would have to be implemented again
within two years of when the reserve
mass has been granted obviously we've
just got the application in we haven't
consulted on it yet and obviously then
we'll have to assess it go through a
public consultation and then potentially
they would be able to start it
within those two years after granting
but obviously that doesn't necessarily
mean that then
you know say within four years we've got
to the point where the role is is
downgraded at that point because
obviously the development is likely to
be built out phase one then two then
three um with the projections in the
local plan um
you know um
annual monitoring report
basically outlines it from 2022 onwards
and goes out just goes outside the plan
period as well to 2031. so it is you
know it's phased to occur effectively
over the next 10 10 years or so so
shouldn't the new road be built first
and then
there's no traffic coming that way that
needs to bring
things onto the
development side
so the road
it has to be provided before any
dwellings on phase three such the west
of the new hayne road are provided so
phases one and two
everything to the to the east of the
hane road can be built out using the
existing hanging road
but anything of the
just just over 300 units i think it is
if anything's um you know occupied on
the other side the road has to be
provided with that so the road doesn't
come through first as part of the
mansion green development it comes
through partially part of the way
through
thank you again
microphone pat
pat my friend
casagana
thank you yeah i just wanted to get a
clarification
question about
the other development that you've talked
about which are to be developed in three
phases one two three
um phase one they're gonna dig the
footings
so just to show we've made a start but
there isn't a builder at the moment to
take that on
um and then i'm assuming that obviously
phase two which has just been issued the
plan that pressure's just finished for
consultation
whether we
whether that's
approved or not
that won't start until after phase one's
finished
and then which hasn't started yet and we
haven't got a bill before
and then um phase three
i assume won't start either until phase
two
has
started and being completed so we've got
a whole chain of development
which is stuck at the first hurdle at
the moment by the sound of it because we
haven't got anyone to actually build it
um and it does sort of link him with
this application because if this
application
was before us
where and phase one
had been started and was
looking like it was going to be
completed with this would maybe be being
viewed much more favorably than it is
now but as it is this can't really be
viewed favorably until phase one has at
least been started and we don't know
apart from footings being dug we don't
know when that's going to
be anywhere near completion
i thank you cal scholar um
totally understanding where you're
coming from there and back to uh mr
jameson
thanks um yeah that's that's correct the
one thing i'd say is that we are aware
that there are various interested
parties in phase one and phase two
um obviously we're not party to all of
the um the discussions between the
land agent who's got the option on the
development and you know signing
contracts with house builders um
all that we have confirmed is that as
you say it's going to be implemented
they are looking they're doing
everything they can to get it to be able
to implement it to keep it alive as a
consent um but yes we don't have a
completion date as yet obviously it may
be that things move
at a pace if things are sought out with
a house builder in october but but
officers still feel that even with that
happening we're not going to get to the
point where phase one has been totally
implemented before theoretically this
development has been completed for just
six houses rather than 220 and the
roundabout also being part of that
scheme as well the roundabout has to be
completed as well before any of the
phase one development is occupied so
there are lots of things that have to
happen
before um you know before
the various links are put in place
uh thank you
councillor wing did i see your
that thank you i saw i thought i saw you
wave at me there for a moment no okay
thank you
any other speakers uh members i'm sorry
you can't come back i'm sorry no i'm
sorry
members um
i think you've had a fair debate there
and very interesting as well so
at this point i'm going to move that to
the officer's recommendation is adopted
and which are aware of is this stage to
refuse
can i have a
show of hands here please for those in
favor of the officer's recommendation
please show
those against
abstentions
the officer recommendation has been
adopted
thank you members uh thank you mr thank
you
hi i'm sorry
you'd have to contact mr livingston
moore
and
well
after the meeting for
in office hours
thank you members so that concludes
public speaking um for this meeting i
will call upon the clerk to read out the
remaining planning applications
as usual if there are any member wishes
to reserve one of those applications
will they
please go call out and we will make a
note of it james
hey chair so we have two remaining items
which is 25a edith road in ramsgate
and
uh the land a date adjacent to two sharp
alice at the place sorry in ramsgates
i could i could say something i'm not
going to
no nothing at all counter orbit um
okay members i didn't see any hands or
words come up so um
can i have a proposal to move that the
application that had not been reserved
be determined in accordance with the
officer's recommendation
um
do i have a second please
counselor coleman cook
i
yes a proposal i have i mean first i
don't mind proposing but
councillor rusevsky thank you council
zesky
and we have a seconder uh the members
agree
thank you
uh for those members of the public i
know we don't have any but i will ask
clark to read out the applications that
have just been determined
okay thanks jeff so that was 25 a edith
road landscape and the second one land
adjacent to two shah place in landscapes
thank you james
well that's it
thank you very much members um
can i just can can i just make uh just
can i just make a comment share please
uh when the when the the clark reads out
those
uh say like in this case those two apple
applications instead of just reading out
the address can it can
for the members of the public who are
looking online or on what they can say
25 edith road
is approved and she would antwens and
two sharp plays for deferral because it
wasn't said so i just think that's
important that that needs to be said
shared for the public thank you thank
you very much for that councilman i
think you've said it i think i believe
we're still online but thank you for
that and that's a good point for
future meetings thank you
members thank you very much for your
time this evening
until next